the LCS is dying but two teams might be
in worse shape R's president of Esports
John needam announced that both golden
Guardians and Evil Geniuses are leaving
the LCS bringing the league down to only
eight teams golden Guardians is owned by
the Golden State Warriors who have
decided to get out of League to focus on
basketball unfortunately their players
were completely blindsided by the
decision and they'll likely have a hard
time finding a new team this late in the
off season but for EG things are a bit
more extreme the or is reportedly set to
leave Esports alt together by the end of
the year despite winning the biggest
valerant event of the year the or has
been an absolute dumpster fire they're
being sued by one of their former DOTA
players they're laying off basically
everyone and there are plenty of
allegations of mismanagement so are we
seeing the end of one of Esports oldest
ORS